but you ought to take act the voice
lessons and this and that and you don't
want to do any I know you know want to
do the same thing reason why I didn't do
well in schools because if I had a test
I wouldn't do it until that morning
study here which sometimes works for
some people like I've always been a
great question procrastinator for you
did you get good grades in school Steve
Hays B's oh wow okay when you were a
freshman I was in high school and we had
the same math class oh wow so you were a
senior he was a freshman you're a
classic you're a little yeah I don't
remember what happened so you're
probably algebra so my brother was in
regular freshman and I'm in [ __ ] class
yeah like that's new never excuse just
never excelled in school I'm done even
though you're not done not done but even
in junior college you didn't you didn't
I would go to a good structure
yeah he doesn't like it I'll go to a
room there's Palomar campus is the
comitia pounds and Marcos they had these
like little rooms that you could just
walk in and there's a piano you'd play
the piano just gonna piano for eight
hours
you're just a creative person they say
now that the the rate of graduation has
actually gone up because high school is
so much less boring like there's they
you know they could tail it to more of
what works for a learner like him or a
learner like you not everybody learns
the same way right yeah so they're
trying to curriculum to make it kind of
more specific to one student like you're
a science ago you want to build a snow
castle whatever they do you know and
they I build one they don't have
subjects anymore so they learn it in
like a more holistic type of way so I
hear that high school is so much more
fun now than when we were in high school
which sucks
I [ __ ] yeah it's like high school was
like high school was like then you'd be
in biology class and you don't
understand a word they're saying
right and then you I learned how to
sleep with my eyes open no I did I could
fall asleep with my eyes up
yeah full of deep sleep with my eyes
open
and then one time my junior year I was
such a bad kid they had me you know like
they had regular desks but then they had
a desk for me with the walls right so I
had it was not last row but I had the
walls so cuz they knew I was gonna
listen anyway so it just sit there at
one time
and then mr. what would you forgot his
last name but he looked he went over the
wall yeah I was like this and he didn't
say anything
do you watch what he saw he caught me
Jericho not oh my god I mean I guess
I've done that too we had a substitute
teacher mr. Holt yeah and we were
there's two parts of the chemistry room
there's the board the chairs are at and
then there's a lab behind it and I guess
I blew someone while he cuz he put on a
movie he was like the laziest substitute
teacher so he was just kind of like in
class the lab in the middle of class
class dad I really liked him I really
liked it was my crush of all crushing
never do that with me you wouldn't blow
me in a [ __ ] class you take him to a
science lab right now I've blown you in
the weirdest places ever what are you
talking like three places I want to know
oh three because he here's another thing
I used to do it all he is when I was
coming because when I was using I would
ditch class meth yeah I would ditch
class and I would go to the [ __ ]
library of the school and I would read
scientific like books about like weird
sexual [ __ ] and I would jerk off in the
[ __ ] library who were your friends in
high school like his did you guys know I
was on the wrestling team and that was a
Christian I was a part of that stew
doing she was he was he was not even
more Christian he was like one of those
I was a die-hard like oh yeah the Bible
and then paste the [ __ ] pages on the
hall yes the verses it was like you know
hardcore chorded do you still pray I
don't believe in religion anymore when
did that happen for you know maybe yeah
maybe in college when I took acid or
something it's something shifted I'm
like this is just yeah she's all
[ __ ] because there's other there's
other dimension in my dorm room and
there's dead people this is not making
sense right now what I've learned you
know I mean this [ __ ] what they've
taught me you throughout all you know
all this shit's not real you know I
always feel like Bible literalists are
are I always I always associate people
who are Bible literalist with some type
of like mental disorder like every time
I some you know how people like any time
you speak to them they're so like
blindly faithful that they just recite
back verses that you instead of trying
to like reason with you I think there's
a degree of like psychological like
unwellness there but they also have they
don't have the real product of our
environment right and we have to
understand that right so it's like when
somebody is a jihadist and they're doing
I mean it's in my eyes evil and bad but
it's not as if they were raised with
that right I mean it's like if we were
in that summation is what you know
that's all they know
yeah yeah so it's like but I you know if
I was a Christian I would make an
assumption that listen were a product of
our environment and if somebody doesn't
believe right not judge them and just
understand that they just were raised
you know mean differently and they were
exposed to different things so what do
you since I know that he talks about God
removing his addiction what what is your
God like when you I I can't really you
know there's no name attached to it but
it's not like do you believe God removed
your addiction God that's God has put me
on the spot I mean in a way it does
because it's a Power greater than
yourself well we can't label it yeah
but yeah I just I literally feel I'm not
getting this is real this is I really do
believe and I don't know why I believe
this and I thought I've had this cause
of discussion with kalila that some
spiritual power has literally removed it
because I used to be a fiend I mean it's
like I love it I love the taste of beer
more than like
anything yeah it's like wheat soda to me
you know like that obsessions been
removed I don't know when that happened
but somewhere along the line of my
sobriety I just didn't feed for it
anymore you know what I mean but you do
you think you didn't do that though no I
come on right so you believe I could've
got beer tonight I went to Trader Joe's
I know but you believe though that like
something intervened
yeah I just don't know what that is I
don't want to put a name on it it is
what it is you just can't something out
there I we can't see yeah and then
religious people the reason was and they
they oh they that they're they're so big
on like if you don't believe the way we
believe you're going you know what I'm
saying like you're going to hell it's
like dude like come on dude you can't
really damn people like that there are a
lot of like different sects of
Christianity now that are so open their
soul right to like the LGBTQ you know
some of the principles I did like the
principle some Christian principles I
did you know but just not the whole
damnation part or I think you're going
to hell or whatever I think most
Christians that I know aren't like that
most Christians that I know are
reasonable people every Christian I know
thinks that maybe have gay friends but
they think that it's an abomination not
probably they are though how are they
questioned if they don't believe that I
think they go to church do you believe
in God they do goodwill they they
believe your Christian friends even
tolerance I understand but it doesn't
matter they're gonna go to heaven
nonetheless
yeah they don't they don't subscribe to
that portion it's not reality then I
feel like that's better like an older
way of thinking that people still
subscribe to but not a lot of Christian
[Music]